this meeting is being recorded
welcome everybody to this 30-minute
meeting we have on Wednesday nights with
Dr Joel Wallach so legally we must say
that this meeting is for educational and
entertainment purposes only what you
hear tonight is not intended to diagnose
treat or cure that being said it takes
great discipline and changes in our
mindset and habits to have the protocols
work and because we know that pigs are
cured and dogs heal so we are here to
seek true science-based clinical advice
on the use of nutrition to feel better
if you have a desire to make a 90-day
change in your lifestyle you've come to
the right place Dr Joel Wallace research
and the development team has created an
army while raising his children from a
Boathouse a zoo and on the road to be
respectful I ask you all to please write
down your questions mute your phones and
in 15 minutes we can open up the lines
for your questions and now without
further ado
Dr Joel wallet okay well thank you Pam
thank you Dave and thank you Laura for
setting all this up and we'll start out
very quickly here today we're going to
talk about connective tissue we're
talking about the skin we're talking
about arteries and veins we're talking
about tendons and ligaments we're
talking about heart valves
um we're talking about
um and see here the bone matrix the disc
between the vertebrae I mean just think
how many
parts of your body and how many tissues
are connective tissue okay
and it requires an enormous amount of
nutrition to maintain this because you
know things are going like crazy and I
always like to start out with the skin
because you can see that okay it's hard
to see your heart valves but you can see
your skin and it's not unusual for
people to have psoriasis psoriasis comes
in many forms change your skin different
colors you get raised
sort of itchy things uh cracks in the
skin
and so forth you can lose your hair hair
fall out the hair turns gray none of
this has to do with aging it's all due
to nutritional deficiencies okay and
then of course same way with arteries
and veins you get blockages in there and
this can be due to deficiencies of the
nutrients to maintain the walls of the
arteries and veins which are again
connective tissue and elastic tissue
which is a kind of connective tissue
and
um
it's one of those things where you have
to say okay what are we going to do here
we have to appreciate that again uh we
we require 90 cents nutrients okay 60
minerals 16 vitamins 12 ounces of Three
fatty acids and it's one of those things
where
we cannot make them that's why they're
essential nutrients we're we require
these things to be consumed okay in
either workable Farms or easily
transmittable forms from raw materials
to the good stuff okay
and
so we have what we call the Healthy
Start pack okay we have the healthy
brain and heart pack the healthy Shard
pack has 90 essential nutrients in it
um and then when we started looking at
bone matrix and Bone problems and things
like that and arthritis
um we in osteoporosis now we started
adding to the 90th Century nutrients uh
collagen glucogel was called originally
and of course our famous basketball
player Theo Ratliff 24 years old
um and he lost his uh spot you know with
the Atlanta Hawks because he's only 24
years old but he had bone to bone
arthritis and Bose knees uh all doctors
wanted to do is give him a double knee
replacement he couldn't play basketball
anymore so they the team terminated him
and took away his 35 million dollar
contract and he came to us to his Pastor
uh because we've been working with his
church for many years and they told us
the story says okay we'll come up with
something so he had the Healthy Start
pack we didn't have anything to regrow
cartilage and ligaments and tendons so
he created the glucogel okay which is
our first collagen product added that to
it so that became a healthy Bone and
Joint pack and we we came up with that
for Theo Ratliff and in a couple of
months he gets his position back and he
plays for 11 more years and makes a
hundred million dollars okay from having
the healthy Bone and Joint pack now we
also came up about three or four months
after we came up with a healthy brainer
heart pack
that came up with the
um let's see here we came up with a
rebound or sports drink with 100
nutrients in it including some of these
things that are required by the
connective tissue in all tissues of the
body all the connected tissue everywhere
okay and so this is not something that's
new uh this is not something that um we
um accidentally fell onto we actually
put it together based on knowledge of
what these tissues required your skin is
kind of like the red warning light okay
for many things including of course
deficiencies of the raw materials for
connective tissue and again bone matrix
bone because the minerals sit on a
connective tissue
tube okay and that's made out of as I
said connective tissue okay and then the
arteries and veins valves for the heart
and tendons that hook to the heart
valves to the muscles in the heart okay
and
but the skin to me is always kind of
interesting because you have the sweat
glands in there and it help keeps you
cool it also gets rid of poisons but
through the sweat you sweat out the
poisons and you you cool Your Body by
sweating
um and
um it's one of those things where uh
Years also you have antibodies in your
sweat and the sort of oils in your skin
if you will and
um
this this protects you against viruses
bacteria fungus and yeast so this
connective tissue we call skin and of
course it has the hair follicles in your
skin and that make hair okay so it has
an enormous wide berth of things that
it's required to do it requires
all 90 essential nutrients and of course
we throw in the extras in the health
Iranian heart pack it has the 215
nutrients the core of which is the 90.
and then we like to throw in
again the MSM the collagen peptides
and
um
the
glucogel we have the collagen sticks and
so on and that will and also the rebound
resource shrink has 75 minerals in it
and 25 vitamins amino acids
when you look at rebound okay or now
let's let's go to Red Bull let's go to
Red Bull or you when you look at Red
Bull it only has one mineral in it
magnesium and the B vitamins come from
um the what should I say The Leftovers
when the factories make beer and wine
and whiskey and stuff like that okay and
so the bee vitamins come from that and
that's it we we put 100 nutrients in our
sports drink they only put one mineral
we have 75 minerals okay we have 25
vitamins amino acids they have I think a
total of four between the amino acids
and vitamins okay and so we have so many
successful athletes have been broken
down and they come back including
Evander Holyfield okay lost his title
because he had a heart attack
okay had a heart attack the connective
tissue in his heart was falling apart
and we came up okay with him with a
healthy brain and heart pack he came
back and nine months later and beat up
Mike Tyson and got his Heavyweight
Championship back who who comes back
from a near fatal heart attack and beats
up a Mike Tyson two referees had to jump
in the ring and stop the fight because
Mike Tyson was knocked out and was just
standing on his feet and his arms down
and and um Evander Holyfield was just
beating the snot out of him so they
stopped the fight and he got his
championship back even though he had
that near fatal heart attack couple
months earlier okay because we took care
of his connective tissue so with all
that said
and we have the products we have the
experience we have the books and CDs
um and so I do want you to get a hold of
the book The Wallach
okay the Wallach Revolution and there's
two famous people okay one of which was
Pat Boone he wrote the forward to the
book there because he had terrible
arthritis I mean he was going to have a
double knee replacement because of his
connective tissue and his knees and his
hips and his vertebrae were on going
down the tubes and we got him on our
healthy Bone and Joint pack that we had
made for our Theo Ratliff and got him
repaired and of course
um then the second one we had
um he wrote the forward okay
Pat Boone wrote the forward to this book
and then the second one Danny Glover
wrote the last chapter in the book
because he had Epi what was it called he
had um uh he was having
um seizures okay and then he had uh all
kinds of stuff going on there with um uh
seizures and seizures needs to Doc in
the wheelchair huh
wasn't he in a wheelchair he had need
bad knees too
yeah but that wasn't his thing that was
that was that was
um uh Pat Boone uh he had seizures and
also happy
what
were you having epilepsy there you go
you had epilepsy okay and so we actually
rebuilt him and he came back and he
didn't he didn't need to be in a
wheelchair anymore because he wasn't
having seizures and but it didn't have
epilepsy anymore and so he wrote the
last chapter in the book in here and so
nobody can argue with those stories
because it's these these people who were
involved in the stories they're telling
their stories so it can't be oh yeah
well if you're making all that up so get
this book the Walt Revolution it's a
75-year track record
all the things we've done to repair and
replace
worn out and damage connective tissue
okay so be with us and guess what you
will do great and don't forget the book
Hell's Kitchen because
there's a transition
at three o'clock in the afternoon Monday
September 4th 1882
um when we went from wooden and coal is
fuel we're putting the wood ashes into
our food and our Gardens for thousands
and thousands and thousands of years
long before the Old Testament okay and
that's where we're getting our minerals
once we went to electricity there was no
more no more ashes
and doctors say oh just eat well you get
everything you need well that's because
they had forgotten we weren't getting
our wood ashes anymore we weren't
getting our minerals whatever necessary
to take care of what oh the connective
tissue and everything from your skin to
your heart to your lungs just seeing all
the cartilage and everything in your
lungs you're trachea and everything
um every every
tissue and system requires connective
tissue support
and so we're so very proud of that okay
don't forget to book Hell's Kitchen
it'll add the information had 25 to 50
Health years your life shaving your arms
unnecessary misery saving an enormous
amount of money okay with that let's go
to
the next part here let's go to some
questions
hello
I see a 212 number go ahead
hi hi this is Barry how Dr Wallach hi
all right okay I have a question here
now I have a polyp in me they took
several polyps out I was in the rehab
center two years ago
because I had a bladder spasms and they
took out bladder stones and then had
blood clots on the lungs and that whole
thing
all right now I have they took out some
polyps
they took out a big one that's like 30
milliliters and it had cancer leeches on
it and there's a 50 milliliter one they
couldn't get out they said it would take
a two to three hour
operation to kick it out but they said
they'd rather take two feet of my colon
out because they said since the 30
milliliter had cancer Legions on it I
have cancer in my colon now they did
ultrasound they did MRIs and everything
they didn't sign Cancer anyplace else in
my body
so let's stop there because we only have
moments here so what I should do is get
rid of all the bad foods get a hold of
my book doctor always cooking without
the bad foods 300 pages of safe recipes
cooking recipes and also uh cooking
recipes I said cooking methods and
recipes also it goes into the good food
bad food list okay Doctor always cooking
without the bad foods and then I also
because you have all this stuff going on
uh let me ask you one pertinent question
here how many times you wake up at night
to urinate once three times five times
I don't wake up because I have a
catheter in me right now okay well
before you head to catheter how many
times did you wake up to urinate
once or twice okay yeah the odds are you
have osteoporosis of the skull squeezing
the spinal cord
okay and squeezing blood vessels and
squeezing the spinal cord
and so you're getting all these issues
all over the place okay and
you got to stay away from the bad foods
which causes polyps bad foods cause
polyps okay
it's an inflammatory thing and so you
have to stop doing all the bad stuff
pops are not genetic pops are not
autoimmune they don't just sort of
appear you cause them by eating
incorrectly okay and so this is very
simple stuff
um again get that book doctor always
cook about the bad foods that'll put you
in the right path
um how much you weigh sir
225 now okay I want you to take the two
healthy brand heart packs a month to
follow those thing twice a day okay then
once you get the MSM take three of those
the breakfast at lunch at dinner time
it'll be two bottles a month and once
you get two of the canisters so the
collagen peptides you can take three or
take a scoot without your morning drinks
or their evening drink okay
and then
um again you want to make sure you're
taking the rebound or Square shrink no
other other than just water you can have
we have decaf coffee we have wonderful
coffee uh with young jeevi it was good
but also I drink our rebound I take two
doses of that a day we have it in sticks
we have it in canisters we have in cans
with the cans you do have to pop the
tops the night before uh put two of them
in the refrigerator because they do have
um carbonation in them
pop the topspin refrigerator at night I
drink one at breakfast and I drink a
half of one at noon and then the other
half of the second one I drink during
the afternoon so my energy is up all
afternoon and of course this occurs when
people have
osteoporosis as hell okay this is
connective tissues as these autopsy
we're taking the top of the skull off
you're looking down on the brain the
skull is a quarter of an inch thickness
and normal there's also an autopsy we
took the top of the skull off looking
down in the brain but here this skull is
an inch and a half to two inches thick
and that scar tissue that's that bone
the squeezing the 12 pairs of cranial
nerves are squeezing the spinal cord
causes 37 different diseases all of
which each disease is a chapter
in a book here okay and it's one of
those things where
um
these doctors went to all these
surgeries and all this and the other and
really in most cases all you need is
nutrition
and stay away from the bad stuff and all
this stuff goes away
okay because connective tissue has an
enormous capacity
to heal and reorganize and go back to
normal if you give it the stuff
but if you just keep damaging it with
fried foods and processed meats you know
with all the nitrates and nitrates in it
um uh you're going to have a struggle
and so you want to take care of your
connective tissue no matter where it's
at whether it's in your brain or your
heart your lungs your your kidneys
um
your intestines your liver and of course
it doesn't hurt to throw in what we call
the gallbladder in a bottle uh throw in
our alt enzymes take your body weight
I'd go ahead and take two or three of
those say five or ten minutes for each
meal a couple ounces of water either way
142 and I take two or three before each
meal I don't care the couple ounces of
water
so I'm sure to absorb all the nutrients
I'm taking as a supplement but also
um digesting my food and absorbing my
essential fatty acids because we put
bile we actually get bile from a
slaughterhouse from the cows they
slaughter we take their gallbladders and
dry the the bile and put in our I think
we're the only ones that put bile into
our
enzymes okay we call them the
gallbladder bottle or ultimate enzymes
so that's going to help you out too
right so okay every couple of weeks let
us know how you're doing any time to go
visit the doctor and you get some kind
of status report let us know
we'll walk you through this okay
all right all right thank you okay okay
well back to you Pam and Dave
anybody else have any questions if not
I'd like to ask in regards to somebody
who just had surgery a new kidney and
what would you suggest for them to have
um this is a this is a kidney transplant
yes okay yeah well of course they need
to have all the stuff that's necessary
to make the kidney happy which is a
healthy brain and hard pack the ultimate
daily plastic tablets which support
healthy blood pressure and healthy blood
flow through blocked arteries because
your kidneys require a lot from your
arteries okay because they're getting
the dirty blood okay taking the the
nasty stuff out of the contaminated
artery blood and then also
um the kidneys uh when you have
um what osteoporosis and stuff like that
you're getting more
um stuff going on in the periphery so
getting more high blood pressure and
um this is where you want to be taking
the ultimate enzymes or your gallbladder
bottle
and um I I like the ultimate daily
classic tablets I only weigh 142 and I
take three of those twice a day
to support healthy blood flow through
blocked arteries whether it's in the
brain the heart to kidneys
and um
it works every time
okay
okay thank you so much uh Laura you have
a question
uh yes hi actually hello it's not really
for me I have a customer on the line her
name is Pamela as well and she would
like to ask a question she called in so
we don't know how to raise the hand for
dialing in go ahead Pam
hello hello quick question
star six to unmute star six to unmute
okay we got a problem here hey Pam it's
your turn
hi
um thank you again for this opportunity
Laura and Dr Wallach I'm very pleased um
I I have a question mostly about dosage
and
um I was diagnosed uh several years ago
my first bone density they said I had
osteoporosis it was really bad and told
me take Fosamax which I said no I think
this might be a testimony for
um subsequent to that I take the tangy
tangerine and I take every day the Osteo
FX and two years later there's they
don't they said my hips are normal which
several years prior they didn't think it
was so great but I'm going to an
endocrat endocrinologist who is now
saying oh raging osteoporosis in your
spine your your bone density doesn't
look so great and go on a
parathyroid uh made in the lab medicine
that just about a year ago was Black Box
FDA bad not take anyway I said no and my
question I'm about 100 pounds how much
you weigh um Dr Wells about 100 pounds
around 100 pounds and I'm 5'2
okay all right so you stay away from all
the bad foods no fried foods no
questions no oils no glutens no wheat no
brought around oats no buckwheat uh no
sugar no carbonate or drinks even the
dad drinks got to go and carbonated
water gotta go and then 100 pounds I
want you to have one healthy brain and
heart pack a month take a half of those
already have breakfast half a dose every
dinner time I also want you to have
in your case I want you also to take the
MSM go ahead and get two bottles a month
of our MSM so you take three breakfasts
three with laundry dinner time they're
going to help repair cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue discs between
the vertebrae bone makes your bone
itself and the skull uh the vertebrae
your hips your knees fingers toes every
place jaw etc etc
okay
and uh also I also want you to take the
um in addition I want you to take our
rebound or sports drink uh as opposed to
just bottled water and that kind of
stuff you need more minerals and of
course our rebound is built with
minerals to supply these minerals to
athletes who sweat out an enormous
amount of minerals okay and at 100
pounds I weigh 142 and I drink two doses
of the rebound a day so you could have a
half a dose rebound twice a day that's
your body weight okay which would be
um you know one of these sticks a day so
there's 30 of these sticks in a box so
this would be good for a month you know
uh in the box of these sticks and then
we have the cancer there's 36 servings
in the canister okay and then of course
yeah yeah
okay that's the rebound and that's going
to give you more minerals okay
and then
enzymes your enzymes I just wanted to
throw in that the enzymes that I
received and I started taking the last
couple weeks is like a game changer I I
just feel so much better
um is that something else I should
continue taking along with glucose you
take forever right I take three of those
enzymes with each meal okay
should I say also I'm on your selenium
should I continue that as well as do you
want to live
yes sir yes
should I continue to breathe of course
yeah colloidal silver is good I take a
dropper full of that and under two
drivers fall under my tongue when I wake
up in the morning two drivers still
under my tongue my fiber Tim is for
breakfast five or Tim is for lunch and
five ten minutes for dinner time and
then again 10 15 minutes before bedtime
I go through two of these bottles of
colloidal silver per month okay and they
kill viruses bacteria fungus and yeast
and it's very important and the support
your immune system
and you have to appreciate that
penicillin only kills gram-positive
bacteria the only penicillin only kills
staphylococcus and streptococcus doesn't
touch any
um of the viruses or any other bacteria
and so you're really really committing
suicide and you just take penicillin
when you have all these infections and
almost got any other throw in the
colloidal silver
um there's no alcohol in it you can even
use it in open wounds you can put it in
babies eyes because there's no alcohol
in it okay any place there's infection
go with the colloidal silver okay
thank you so much I so appreciate all
your help and God bless you we love you
keep up the great work and tell your
story to everybody okay
I am I am thank you
okay
all right thank you so much Pamela and
how old are you Pam if I may ask
I'm 64. I'm a brown Belton karate I'm
getting my black belt within a year I
ride a horse four times a year for the
last 20 years
I work out every day I do weights six
times a week
and I have listened to Dr Wallach for
over 20 years but I wasn't religiously
taking the uh youngevity product the um
when you're sweating you need to see
when you sweat you're not just sweating
out water you're sweating out nutrients
as well so you really need to be taking
these nutrients at the levels we spoke
about here to replace what you're
sweating out
I think an ounce of um the liquid
colloidal minerals
um you know the green bottle after I
work out I take an ounce is that is that
good enough do you think yeah well well
don't add that to your rebound
oh oh great thank you add that to your
rebound
one last question
wouldn't you say more complete
okay complete thank you thank you sir
did you want to ask one more question
Pam
I did it's it's about these um from Dr
Wallace perspective about drugs
um the
osteoporosis drugs
um I I don't unders I don't understand I
I understand from a revenue stream
perspective
drugs just resolve symptoms they don't
fix the problem
this is why we have the MSM this is why
we have the
um let's see here we have the MSM we
have the glucogel we have the collagen
peptides
wait that's because
and we have the re we have the rebound
all to maintain repair bones and
ligaments and tendons and connective
decisions including the skin
thank you okay
perfect I'm glad you mentioned about the
ultimate
um enzymes that's fantastic okay and we
have uh Dave your hand is up I want to
give a quick testimony docson since
connective tissue night
um I've had three major wrecks in my
life I shattered my ankle on my right
leg I broke that same leg in three
places I shattered my pelvis and I fell
down my basement stairs 33 years later
shattered my callus bone they had said I
had an 80 chance I was going to lose
that foot now without going into the
Gory details the the wreck that I had
second in 1979 I had a crack in my shin
bone my Taos bone 10 inches long it
looked like a lightning bolt it was a
half inch deep and a half inch wide my
leg was swollen and ugly and in pain all
the time after I recovered from the fall
down my basement stairs and that was 11
years ago they said I'd lose my foot
within five years I'd be begging them to
amputate I still have my foot I walk
pretty darn good
it's not a hundred percent but it's
about 99 and that 33 year old wound that
I had in my leg healed I didn't even
know it I I I was rolling around on the
floor with my grandson and I want him to
feel that crack in my leg and I went to
feel it and it disappeared the pain was
gone and it was because it was chronic
you know pain I did I didn't even know
it was gone I forgot all about it until
I went to reach for it to find it it
filled in because I was taking glucogel
capsules 16 a day and I was drinking
about two or three ounces of the
glucogel liquid while I was recovering
in a wheelchair for six months healing
my foot and when I finished when I got
out of that chair and I rehabbed they
had to teach me how to walk again I was
walking a 17 minute mile on the
treadmill and I never did that in my
life nice
so I'm 64 now and uh yeah I get around
pretty good
so thank you doc okay God bless you guys
for all of us women out here
give Mom okay give her something that's
going to help her connective tissue
including her skin and all her arteries
and lungs and so forth and heart valves
but also give her something that's good
for her
um uh girly stuff okay okay we have all
kinds of girly stuff and so look at look
at our list of early stuff and give Mom
something that's going to make her happy
including you know we have all this hair
stuff
um gray hair has nothing with ages due
to a nutritional deficiency get her on
our our
um Hair Skin and nails and her hair
color will come back and she'll look 25
years younger
thank you Dr Wallach we love you
have a great time thank you thank you
bye-bye hey by the way I wanted to say
real quick thanks for speaking to
another customer I had today she called
you on the radio show she was so happy
to speak to you that you gave her you
gave her the answer to a long problem
that she's had she was in tears when she
called me she was so thankful well the
main thing she's happy and we're going
to help her we give God all the credit
and we're just we're just as the we're
just the instrument thank you thank you
thank you
thank you very much see you next week
you bet yeah bye-bye thank you everybody
hi guys
bye bye thank you
have a good night and a better tomorrow